a gaussian mixture model also known as
GMM is a statical model used to describe
data distribution it assumes that the
data can be represented as a combination
of multiple gaussian distributed models
each with its own mean and variance in
practice this means that we can model
complex distributions such as the
distribution of test scores or income by
combining multiple simple distributions
such as distribution of a test score of
girls and for boys using GMM to model a
distribution allows us to capture the
complexity of the data and described it
more accurately this can be particularly
used in machine learning application
where we often deal with complex and
high dimensional data sets let's now
deeply understand the gazian mixture
model and gaussian mixture distribution
so without any further Ado let's jump on
to our topic but wait to succeed in this
rapidly expanding field you need to
develop the right skill if you want to
boost your career in the field of ml
then take up our Celtic postgraduate
program in aimml partnership with IBM
that will help you become an expert in
Ai and ml this course covers the latest
tools and Technologies and features
master classes by Celtic facility and
IBM experts hackathon and ask me session
are also there these are a few reasons
you should consider learning machine
learning now enroll in Celtic
postgraduate program in Ai and ML and
become an ml engineer the link will be
in the description and pin comment now
let's start this video and see what is
gaussian mixture Model A gaussian
mixture model is a probiotic model
representing data as a mixture of
multiple gaussian distributions it is
mixture model because it assumes that a
data points are generated from a mix of
gaussian distribution a is associated
with a certain probability in GMM each
gaussian distribution represent a
component or cluster within the data the
model assumes that the data points
within each cluster are generated from a
gaussian distribution with its mean and
covariance the GMM which is known as
gaussian mixture model combine these
component distribution with mixture
weight to form the overall probability
distribution of the data so now let's
see the key components of gaussian
mixture model so the number one is
number of components also known as
clusters the GMM assumes that the data
is a mixture of specific number of
gaussian distributions also known as
components or clusters the number of
components is typically determined in
advance or estimated by using techniques
such as model selection
next we have gaussian distribution each
component in the GMM is represented by a
gaussian distribution a gaussian
distribution also known as normal
distribution is a bell-shaped curve
fully described by its mean and
covariance
the mean represents the center of the
distribution and the covariance
determines the spread or shape the third
one is mixtures weight the GMM assigns
mixtures weight to each component
representing the probability of
selecting that component when generating
a data point these weight must sum up to
1 the mixture will determine the
collaboration of each component to the
overall distribution so by using a
gaussian mixture model involves
estimating the model parameters
including the means covariance and
mixture waves this is typically done
through an interactive optimization
algorithm like the exceptional
maximization algorithm the EM algorithm
alternates between the estimating the
sensibilities of each component for each
data point and updating the model
parameters based on the responsibilities
the algorithm continues until
convergence where the parameters reach a
stable State once the G is trained it
can be for various tasks for example it
can be applied to clustering by
assigning data points to the most likely
component or cluster it can also be used
for density estimation where it
estimates the underlining probability
distribution of the data now let's see
what are some real world examples where
gaussian mixture model can be used as in
mixture model also known as gmms are
versatile tool that find application in
various real world scenarios they are
particularly useful when dealing with
large data sets where identifying
clusters is challenging gmms excel at
efficiently discovering clusters of
gaussian outperforming testing
algorithms like k-means now here are
some practical examples of how gaussian
mixture model can be applied the first
one is medical data set analysis
medical images or identify patterns
within message by clustering patients
based on similar symptoms gmms can
assist in detecting diseases subtypes
predicting outcomes and reliving
creations and revealing previously
unknown patterns in large scale patient
records
next we have modeling natural phenomena
MMS are suitable for modeling natural
phenomena with gaussian distribution are
observed in the noise this modeling
approach assumes an underlining
unobserved entities or attributes which
measurements taken at central point
across multiple observation sessions
next we have customer Behavior Analysis
gaussian mixture model are valuable in
marketing for analyzing customer
Behavior by leveraging historical data
gmms can predict future purchases
enabling businesses to tailor the market
strategies and get more efficiently next
one is stock price prediction gaussian
mixture model find applications in
finance especially in analyzing stock
price time series they can identify
challenge points within the data helping
detect turning point in stock price or
other Market movements that might be
obstacle by vulnerability and noise next
we have gene expression data analysis
a model are employed in gene expression
data analysis they can be utilized to
identify differentially expression genes
between two conditions and determine
which genes make you to specific
phenomenal type or disease States now
let's see the implementation of the
gaussian mixture model now to do this
small demo I have taken Iris data set
okay in Python there is gaussian mixture
class to implement GMM load that Iris
data set and then we'll are good to go
first thing we're gonna import is our
numpy which is a library of python okay
so we'll write import
numpy
as
and B
in the next line
we have to import Panda so we'll write
import
panda
as
DD and after that we'll import mat plot
live we'll write report
Lord
then Dot
p y l o t
as
PLT okay
okay till then I guess it's fine for you
guys yeah so now we'll write from pandas
and we will import
data frame
okay after that from scientific learn
which is sk1 we write it we'll Chrome is
okay
we're done really bold
data set
okay and then again from
Escalon
mixture
and import
since
now we'll load the Irish data set so
that will write Irish the name
and then
data set that we just now imported from
sk1 we'll write data sets dot load
because we need to load that data and
we'll write this
this function sign after that
we'll give it a variable X and Irish Dot
data
Chrome
so the semicolon we just wrote is for
everything like all the data when we
have to show all the data we'll write
this a imagine there is a array of seven
things zero one two three four five six
okay and you want everything of that
array so if we'll use this keyword and
if you want only out of that seven if
you want only five so we'll write here
comma and then we'll write 2 so what it
this will show is only five zero one two
three four okay yeah
now we'll write d
which is PD dot data frame
you will see we'll get the data named
from X
it will just declare so this is for the
turn into a data frame for like turning
into my data into a data frame okay
now we have to plot the data for that
we'll write
plot dot scatter
and then we'll write D of
of 1 okay and then we'll say
Plot show
and now let's see if it works or not
okay
it's showing me one error so let's see
okay got it
stick now let's run it again it shows
error again let's see
any spelling mistakes here okay let's
give it a chance again and then some
error is there oh yeah
potassium mixture should be in capital
everything looks fine this time yeah so
you can see the data now you will see
the data of these flowers Irish flowers
it's like everything is mixed you can
identify which one is which and you
can't identify the exact things that you
want to see in this data so for that
cache and mixture comes in so with this
method we'll see the difference between
the things that we want to see in the
data okay so we'll click on the plus
sign and we will write mm Plus in
maximum model equals to sign and
yeah soon it's showing us
again and
two
components equals to three
so we will find the GMM model for the
this data set and if the three gaussian
distribution so that we can see the
different colors for every data set in
this so we'll give GMM dot fit and the
data frame all the data and now we will
just assign a label to each sample okay
for that we'll write label
equals to
GMM
dot predict
the date data
now we'll give this data a label
that will write the
label
labels equals
labeled
okay and
explain and write d0
and we'll give this d0
label
so that we can identify it later and
which one is
the date of ours okay
so we'll again write labels
equals to
0.
0 okay this one is for 0 and we'll copy
this and we'll paste it three times yeah
so because we have taken the components
three if it's more we can use more also
so we have to change the value of T1 D2
and here also we have to change the
values or the output will be not come
like what we want the output to be okay
till now we have assign the label
okay now we'll move forward we'll plot
three clusters in same plot okay so for
that we'll write plot dot scatter
from d0 to comma
d0 and then one and
we'll make this as red you have to write
this straight in the
column so the color should be shown on
the screen
okay
so we can just copy this line and paste
it one two and three okay so we'll
change the value here of d
from
the color too
make it as green okay now as you can see
everything looks good now we'll execute
this code and you will see okay what I
have missed here check again okay we
have to change the color of this
let's make it as
yellow
okay now let's execute this it's again
showing us one error but the fit TMM dot
red D let me check again now as you can
see we have the output and in this
output you can clearly see that this
data which was previously like this
where we can't see which data is For
What and now with this gaussian mixture
method we can see all the output in
different colors so we can say that this
method helps us very much and print the
coverage log like uh hold value and
number of iteration needed for the model
to coverage okay so we need liquid a
little more code to get the value of
that so for that we'll write print
lower
bound
again here and we'll write
print
gnm dot in
yes
okay now let's run this and now you have
the output date and it's the value of
that output okay hence there are seven
iterations for the log like hold to
cover it so in summary gaussian mixture
model represents data as a mixture of
gaussian distribution model the model
parameters including the number of
components mean covariance and mixture
weight are estimated using techniques
like the Expedition maximization
algorithm in mixture model can be used
for clustering data in two groups and
estimating the probability density
function of the data so with this we
have read the end of this video make
sure to like and share this video And
subscribe to Simply learns YouTube
channel thank you staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here